tolin who had an empty net goal here Tuesday night
for the Kraken can't make it happen here's Jason
Dickinson a drop pass for blasic Locker Along
by Joey dord now Larson angles a pass cut off
briefly by Lucas Reichel on a change Devin sha
is fresh here he comes to the slot reel a good
play on Kyler Yamamoto it comes out to Center
Yamamoto two points on Tuesday with a shot he
scores Tyler Yamamoto 1653 left in Period one
the Kraken off and running you see this play
here developing sh throws it through but watch
borgan Step Up right here breaks the play down
the turnover in the neutral zone Yamamoto
brings it right back and here's the shot
moves it inside the Stick of classic great shot
great positioning right underneath that arm but
it's all about borgan stepping up in that play
taking away time and space tolven in takes over
Joey Anderson sets up Pino right in off the side
of the goal and recovering is Joey dor to smother
a great feed from Joey Anderson on his knees to
find Felino going in for the break in you see
right here he's falling down just flips one up
into an area and trying to just go around just
gets a little bit too in tight Felino does the
backhand deferral Larson now done fumbles the
puck gets it back H done circling the track with
it up top Larson now done a one timer they score
Pierre Edward Belmar in the right place at the
right time he adds goals in backto back games
two nothing Seattle from the fourth line they at
it again they've had another great game so far
in this first period and it's just a little bit
of Puck luck it might actually be Yamamoto here
they both take a swipe at it might be a double
hit Yamamoto went first through the line can't
quite tell here but that puck gets blocked out
in front and dropped right there Then stun off
his stick accepted by Oliver Bor strand tolven in
Springs gor he's in stopped solder bloom gets in
the way it goes High through the neutral zone
sauce pass from tolin and sends gourd in on a
break Just Hits Soder Bloom just up high onto
that shoulder good shot here from Yanni trying
to test the goal tender up high over that blocker
side he split time in the American Hockey League
with Rockford and Chicago last season it goes
off a stick in the backtrack by badar great
pass Donato's in stopped by dord the rebound
D cord's got it to send Donado in and again a
second look for denado Rebound goes through he
ends up sending that one towards the five hole
there's the pass that sends Donado in nice save
look how far Joey is out on top of the crease
challenging D Shore good play by Taylor radish
he'll get it out to Center Ice Shore recaptures
the puck for Seattle and a restart three minutes
gone in the second period a steel boiler radish he
scores Taylor radish 1657 left in the
second period Chicago cuts the lead in
half this Puck does not get out it's held
in right here in the Quick Pass from bili
over to radish just beats Joey dord on
that glove side as he tries to slide
over just misses that puck but again it was an
opportunity Seattle did have the puck on their
stick Evans at the point interrupted by Joey
Anderson now Lou creier denied by Bor strand
a sweep check by Crevier on Bor strand
out in front it scores it goes off Jason
Dickinson Oliver Bor strand will get the goal
Seattle recaptures a two goal lead with the
opportunity and Bor strand just finds a little
bit of time he's just throwing this Puck to the
back door trying to hit Yanni Gore with the
pass goes off the skape of Dickinson in front
and pass solder Bloom right here it's pass all
the way sometimes you got to get a bounce you
have to get lucky but a good job by the Seattle
Kraken keeping that puck in Bruce pass broken
up by Brandon tanov has Kier in front they go
to The Far Side look around off of sck borgan
they score a tip out in front will borgan from
downtown 517 left in the second period Ty cier
makes it four to one from tanov and he just gets
on his horse going behind the net finding will
poran at the pool line but look at the layered
screen out in front you have wiberg and Ki as
well that puck is oh so close to go over the blue
line but it's car in front battling for position
ends up getting a stick on this puck right there
and pass solder Bloom and it was Eddie better at
a pearl champ concert this season that announced
Chris chileos night in Chicago this season bers
stopped solder Bloom comes up big and a break
in for Matty bers gets this Puck through just
gets off balance a little bit there by Murphy
but he able to come back here trying to throw
that puck on the five hole for solder cross
ice Bor strand through Center clean entry the
Maestro shadowed by Tyler Johnson Gore out
in front they score that's hockey baby what
a play Elly tolin brilliant finish set up by
Yanni gourd 5 to one Seattle the lineup good
play here delaying cring space Yanni gourd
able to handle that pass right through and
find Tolen and they switch spots right here
on the play causes a little bit of confusion
both players end up taking a Peak at Yanni
Gordon when that pass goes through it's too
little too late not able to recover toen an En of
finding here comes mccan he throws on the brakes
rer Evans this way for Oliver bjorkstrand Evans
little backhand deferral mccan here it comes he
scores Jared McAn with a bomb power play goal the
fifth shot in the power play six to one Kraken
over aggressive on their penalty kill going up top
both forwards are pressing too much time and space
for Jared mccan the D can't go all the way out in
ZF right here mccan downhill that's your look good
screen out in front you're able to blow one right
past solder Bloom but just taking advantage nice
moving screen by Alex wber it's another point
for rer Evans and a big blast from Jared mccan
six on the board tanon Duman he'll play it deeper
now for Devin Shore wedged by Philip Roose Belmar
scores there's a goal for Pierre Edward Belmar
the Kraken get the extra point they lead it 7 to
one in the zone the pucks are going to get
pushed down below like bmar battling out in
front here short nice little play from behind
the net that one's just going to sneak over
the pad and leg of solder Bloom nice job
backing out don't need two players going
to the same Puck finds himself open just
needs a little bit of space and belmar's
able to sneak that one home Cole Gutman broken
up Reichel out of the corner looks to the slot
plays it to the outskirts Nick Pino Center
Point Philip brose here's boiler he'll take
it in out in front dord says no a couple of
times on Felino the second opportunity that
ends up rolling through too Joey's able to
dive across and get and the Kraken to a man
do it again that is their DNA that is Kraken
hockey Baby Tonight a 7-1 win over Chicago